[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au Parlement européen
à Bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro
d'europebdo au menu de cette émission le
Parlement européen a voté une résolution
visant à geler les négociations
d'adhésion de la Turquie à l'Union
européenne hryost le président turc
menace de rouvrir les frontières aux
migrants et puis en 2uxème partie notre
reportage François Goulin est parti
enquêter sur ses centrales nucléaires en
Belgique qui font peur à l'Europe les
nombreuses fuites les fissures voire les
tentatives de sabotage de ces centrales
posent un problème de sécurité mais
d'abord l'actualité c'est la tension qui
monte à nouveau entre la Turquie et
l'Union européenne face aux attaqu
multiples contre les droits de l'homme
du président Erdogan une résolution
visant à geler le procès processus
d'adhésion de la Turquie à l'Union a été
voté en Rost le président turc joue sur
la possibilité d'ouvrir à nouveau la
route de l'Europe aux migrants on
regarde et on réagit juste après avec
nos
invités il est en colère REP tayb
Erdogan le président turque a pris la
parole pour réagir à la décision prise
par le Parlement européen qui demande le
gel des négociations d'adhésion de la
Turquie à l'Union européenne
Erdogan AB brandit la menace des
migrants l'homme sait qu'il a entre les
mains un véritable moyen de
pression quand 50000 migrants s'étaient
amassés à la frontière entre la Turquie
et la Bulgarie vous les Européens vous
avez crié à l'aide vous avez compté sur
la Turquie pour qu'elle ferme ses
frontières si l'Europe continue à nous
mépriser ces frontières nous allons les
ouvrir mettez-vous bien ça dans la tête
la semaine dernière le Parlement
européen a demandé le gel des
négociations d'adhésion en raison de la
féroce répression turque depuis le coup
d'État avorté de juillet vote purement
symbolique cette décision n'appartient
qu'aux états- membres en mars la Turquie
et l'Union européenne ont conclu un Pact
qui a permis d'assécher le flux de
clandestin vers l'Europe si la menace de
rouvrir les frontières est crédible le
président Erdogan prend le risque s'il
mettait ses menaces à exécution de
perdre un levier important son statut de
partenaire indispensable de l'Europe
celui qui fait de lui un homme fort de
la scène
[Musique]
internationale alors nous rejoint sur ce
plateau Philippe Lambertz bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputé belge co-président du
groupe des vers ici au Parlement
européen merci d'avoir accepter notre
invitation Dominique Riquet bonjour vous
êtes eurodéputé français du groupe de
l'alliance des démocrates et libéraux
pour l'Europe en France vous avez été
élu sous les couleurs de l'UDI merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation enfin
jeanem vous vous avez pas été élu sous
les couleurs de l'UD ni des vert vous
étiez même un peu anarchiste sous les
bords à une époque je pas
lancer en tout cas vous êtes le
correspondant de libération dans la
capitale européenne auteur du blog
coulisse de Bruxelles merci d'avoir
accepter notre invitation on vient de
voir le président Erdogan il sait qu'il
a entre les mains un véritable moyen de
pression sur l'Europe est-ce que cette
menace elle est crédible Philippe
Lambert je pense que c'est une menace
qui va continuer àir maintenant est-il
prêt à passer à l'acte il sait très bien
que il est isolé vous rappelez la la
politique de la Turquie c'était avoir
zéro etnemi s'entendre avec tous ses
voisins aujourd'hui la la Turquie a des
problèmes avec à peu près tout le monde
Erdogan se reforge une forme d'alliance
ou d'entente avec la Russie mais la
Russie a une économie qui n'est pas
florissante et donc ne peut pas beaucoup
aider l'économie turque qui a vraiment
besoin besoin d'aide et donc Erdogan a
besoin de l'Europe au moins sur le plan
de débaouuchché économique et donc il ne
peut pas faire n'importe quoi ceci étant
si les Européens avaient la volonté de
faire leur juste part dans l'accueil des
réfugiés herdogan n'aurait tout
simplement pas de bras de levier c'est
parce que comme il l'a très bien dit la
simple le simple risque de voir arriver
50000 réfugiés en en en Europe si ça ça
tétanise les les leaders européens alors
évidemment il faut pas grand-chose pour
les tétaniser vous savez quand bien même
il mettrait à exécution sa menace
d'envoyer en Europe les 3 millions de
réf qui est en Turquie et bien 3 million
de réfugiés sur 508 million d'habitants
c'est même pas 1 % de notre population
donc c'est quelque chose à émite qui
devrait nous faire réagir en disant
chiche ose le faire et tu verras nous on
est capable de les intégrer mais
évidemment le problème c'est queà la
tête des 28 des 28 États de l'Union
européenne il y a des gens qui n'osent
pas tout simplement assumer leur
responsabilité et donc qui ont peur de
se confrontter à ce qu'il pensent être
la dominante de l'opinion publique Dom
l'Europe devrait réagir en disant si je
faisle non je crois pas qu'il faille
dire si je fais-le mais ce qu' atre
clair c'est qu'il est dans une stratégie
d'affrontement avec tous ses voisins
absolument et d'ailleurs avecune partie
de son peuple je crois pas comme
Philippe que on puisse accueillir 3
millions de réfugiés sans que ça pose
d'important problème politique à
l'intérieur de l'Europe on l'a vu bon
alors je me place pas sur un point de
vue moral he ou le devoir d'accueil ou
le devoir d'asile mais on voit bien que
il y aurait des conséquences politiques
en Europe que nous ne souhaitons pas
donc je crois que la discussion continue
et comme ça a été dit ils ont des
dépendances économiques fortes avec nous
il faut discuter c'est clairement un
rapport de force la discussion continue
l'Union européne peut pas claquer la
porte au nez d'Erdogan selon vos propres
mot on est dans un dans un problème
extrêmement complexe avec avec la
Turquie tout simplement parce que le
seul instrument de politique étrangère
réel dont dispose l'Union européenne les
28 agissant ensemble c'est la
perspective de l'adhésion et on est
rentré dans ce jeulà avec la Turquie
lorsqu'on l'a reconnu d'abord le statut
le le statut de pays candidat et
lorsqu'on a ouvert des négociations
d'adhésion en réalité c'est un un
vraiment le bal des fauxus c'est-à-dire
que tout le monde personne n'avait envie
que la Turquie adhère mais c'était le
moyen d'amener la Turquie à se
moderniser et on se disait ça va prendre
10 20 30 ou 40 ans et que peut-être au
terme de ce processus l'Union européenne
et la Turquie se seront suffisamment
transformés peut-être un jour que la
Turquie adhère le problème c'est que ça
marche pas comme ça évidemment donc on
se retrouve surtout on avit pas prévu
l'élection d'Erdogan et le durcissement
brutal autoritaire du régime d'Erdogan à
la suite du coup d'État du mois de
juillet le problème aujourd'hui c'est
que si on la joue morale c'estàdire on
dit aux Turcs écoutez maintenant vous
nêtes plus de démocratie pas tout à fait
une dictature et donc on interrompt
comme vous voudrez faire le Parlement
européen on interrompt les négociations
d'adhésion là on fait de Erdogan un un
un martyr aux yeux de son peuple aux
yeux de la communauté internationale
parce que il VI dire écoutez au moment
du au moment du coup d'État personne n'a
réagi c'est vrai chez les Européens on
attendait tous finalement qu'ils soit
renversé on l'espérait un peu faut dire
les choses comme elles sont et donc il
dit vous m'avez laissé tomber et il
apparaîtra effectivement comme un héros
si on continue les négociations comme si
de rien nétait de facto ça renforce les
tendances autoritairees à l'intérieur du
pays donc on est coincé c'estàdire que
là Erdogan pour ça il est malin il sait
qu'il nous tient donc le but de l'Union
européenne en tous les cas du côté des
chefs d'État de gouvernement c'est de
dire de laisser Erdogan s'enfermer
lui-même dans euh dans dans dans dans en
Turquie c'està-dire que qu'il convoque
son référendum parce qu'il a annoncé
qu'éventuellement au printemps prochain
il a il convoquera un référendum sur la
perspective d'adhésion et qu'il claque
lui-même la porte au nez des Européens
mais notre intérêt une fois qu'on a
commencé à négocier n'est pas de nous de
claquer la porte au nez des Turcs ça
serait vraiment contreproduc c'est un
peu un Serpin de mer cette adhésion de
la Turquie à l'Union européenne est-ce
qu'il faudrait pas une bonne fois pour
toutes dire aux Turcs à la Turquie on ne
vous veut pas en Europe et pas laisser
espérer les Turcs parce que c'est
êre honnête une bonne fois pour si vous
avez raison il faudrait arrêter dire que
de Gaulle de Gaulle avant le début des
négociations d'adhésion avec la
Grande-Bretagne a dit non deux fois mais
si le processus d'adhésion avait
commencé de GA aurait pas pu dire non à
la Grande-Bretagne c'est ça le piège
dans lequel on s'est mis oui ceci étant
la Turquie au début il faut se rappeler
quand même le l'arrivée au pouvoir du
Parti AKP de Monsieur Erdogan s'est
accompagné de progrès considérable de la
Turquie en direction des valeurs
européennes je veux dire il a quand même
renvoyé l'armée dans les cas
il a engagé ce qui était impensable un
processus de paix avec le PKK donc les
séparatistes CDES qui sont quand même
pas des enfants de cœur au Kurdistan et
donc on a vraiment vu une progression
réelle de l'État de droit en Turquie et
c'est vrai que là les Européens n'ont
pas me semble-t-il ont envoyé
rappelez-vous c'éta l'époque merkooszi
où les les messages du PPE le plus grand
parti européen ont été clair écoutez
vous pouvez faire tous les progrès que
vous voulez mais de toute façon ça nous
intéresse pas vous n'avez pas de
perspective d'adhésion je d ça n'est pas
la seule cause qui a fait qu'Erdogan a
pris son virage dictatorial parce que je
crois que c'est ça qu'il faut quand même
bien enfin il faut appeler les choses
comme elles sont mais je pense en tout
cas que ça l'a encouragé à le faire je
veux dire s'il sait que de l'autre côté
de la table il y a des gens qui
négocient pas de bonne foi bah il n'a
plus aucun intérêt à à rapprocher son
tur elle a un avenir oui il y a deux
éléments du contexte qu'il faut rappeler
le premier c'est que les États-Unis ont
beaucoup poussé à l'intégration de la
Turquie dans l'Europe pour des raisons
qui tenent à
l'éol
prob ça il y a des choses qui vont
beaucoup bouger et la deè chose c'est
que la Turquie est intégrée
économiquement dans l'espace européen et
que débouchés son emploi son industrie
sont étroitement corr
donc les armes d'Erdogan qume sont
limité parce que sur le plan économique
là ça pourra êre catastrophique de
couper les P avecur jeisir ce que
disa à propos justement des progrès qu'
av accomli la Turquie voir aussi
qu'Erdogan on l'a sous-estimé depuis le
début en fait il s'est servi de l'Union
européenne pour pousser l'armée ramener
l'armée dans les casernes c'està dire il
a s'est servi des valeurs européennes
pour dire aux militaires non vous n'êtes
plus les gardiens de l'État de droit en
Turquie vous n'êtes plus les gardiens
des droits de l'homme parce que c'est
l'inverse de chez nous pour nous les
militaires historiquement le cas en
Turquie hein depuis Mustapha Kal oui
voilà parce que chez nous le militaire
qui prend le pouvoir c'est le bad guy
c'est pinoché en Turquie C exactement
l'inverse donc il s'en est servi pour
pour ramener pour enfermer les
militaires dans les casernes et
maintenant qu'ils sont dans les casernes
l'Europe ne l'intéresse plus c'est dire
que Erdogan n'a aucun aucune intention
mais vraiment j'en suis persuadé
d'adhérer à l'Union européenne il se
sert de l'Union européenne donc là en
l'occurrence le jeu qui doit être le
nôtre c'est de de le laisser s'enfermer
dans cette logique et de claquer la
qu'il claque la porte lui-même mais
comme le dit très bien criquet c'est que
de toute façon à terme il aura besoin de
nous il est coincé parce que les seuls
débouchés turc qui claquer la porte le
premier alors les turcs ou ou les tur
tur les turces moi je suis persuadé que
ce sont les Turcs aussi on verra on
verra ça on pass en tout cas pr Paris on
verra ça on verra ça tout cas on passe à
la seconde partie de cette émission il y
a le donc le le président turc qui
menace l'Europe avec lesmigrants il y a
aussi ces centrales nucléaires en
Belgique qui font peur à l'Europe les
nombreuses suites les fissures voir les
tentatives de sabotage de ces centrales
posent un problème de sécurité font
craindre à certains un Tchernobyl belge
le reportage de François Goulin avec les
équipe de la RTBF
[Musique]
entre Namur et Liège posé au bord de la
Meuse la centrale de tiange et sa
réputation sulfureuse ici les incidents
sont monnaie courantes en 2 ans les
turbines ont été arrêtées fois pour
finalement être autorisé à redémarrer
l'année
dernière Francis lebout a travaillé dans
cette centrale comme ingénieur
aujourd'hui l'association qui l'a créé
demande l'arrêt définitif de cette bombe
à retardement il y a plusieurs problèmes
donc on a on a un réacteur qui est
vieillissant qui a dépassé les 30 ans
donc ça commence ça commence à devenir
très limite en terme de de de résistance
de matériaux donc on a la présence de
plus de 3000
microfissures qui ajoutent à à la
dangerosité plus personne ne conteste le
fait qu'il y aura un autre
Fukushima s jour dans le monde et ce
sera tiange
ou quelque part en France personne n'en
sait rien mais ça arrivera l'idée d'un
accident nucléaire majeur à tiange
Francis lebut l'imagine depuis des
années et dans une des zones les plus
peuplé d'Europe les conséquences
seraient dramatiques si on avait un
accident majeur de ce type là donc Jean
Fukushima ou tinoby ça signifie tout
simplement la fin de la Wallonie et donc
de la Belgique vu vu vu les conséquences
c'est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que par
rapport au aux accidents de chernoby et
et de Fukushima c'est qu'on a une
densité de population aussi qui est bien
plus grande donc ce sont des millions de
personnes qui seront touchées qui devrai
être déplacé pour la Wallonie c'est
c'est on peut considérer que c'est la
fin la Wallonie n'existe plus quoi c'est
clair une catastrophe digne de Fukushima
en pleine Wallonie même les officiels
belges envisagent ce scénario dans le
plus grand secret Jean-Marc Nolet est
député écologiste il suit le dossier
depuis des années et s'est procuré un
document explosif une lettre du gendarme
du nucléaire
l'AFCN envoyée à la Direction de la
centrale il y a quelques mois j'ai
souligné les valeurs alarmantes des
probabilités de fusion du cœur ses
résultats sont franchement désastreux
j'ai demandé en conséquence une prise en
charge vigoureuse de cette problématique
vous imaginez si y a ça il faut arrêter
les centrales on peut pas simplement
dire voilà on vous envoie un courrier
non si ce qui est dit ce qui est écrit
est vrai il faut en tirer d'autres
conséquences et notamment porter aussi
le dossier en justice non ici l'agence à
la fois elle utilise des termes très
très dur on le voit dans le courrier
mais elle ne fait qu'envoyer un
courrier en plus de l'inaction c'est
l'indépendance de l'agence de contrôle
qui est également en ligne de mire son
directeur Yan Benz est l'ancien patron
de l'autre centrale belge
dou face aux accusations être juge et
parti un audit de l'agence a été demandé
Jean-Marc Nolet s'en est procuré une
copie dont les conclusions sont
accablantes il y a une impression de
perte d'indépendance graduelle de
l'agence par rapport au monde politique
et économique des collaborateurs se
demandent si la direction est poussée à
faire certains compromis s'il y a bien
un endroit un lieu un dossier où
l'agence doit être totalement
indépendante de toute forme de pression
politique économique c'est justement par
rapport aux centrales nucléairire mais
comment voulez-vous qu'il en soit
autrement quand le patron de cette
agence et l'ancien patron de la centrale
de doule c'est il contrôle s'il a bien
fait son job il y a 10 ans quoi c'est
pas possible évidemment il faut
renforcer l'indépendance et le regard
International est un des moyens pour
renforcer l'indépendance de notre agence
Mayan Benz est également un personnage
au passé trouble il a lui-même raconté à
la presse qu'il avait distribué des
enveloppes de cash à des intermédiaires
au Kazakhstan lorsqu'il travaillaient
dans le nucléaire suite au tolet suscité
par ces révélations c'est le silence
radio ni la FCN ni la centrale de tiange
n'ont voulu répondre à nos questions
seul le principal syndicat du site a
accepté de nous parler en tant que
travailleur on doit accepter les
décisions de l'agence fédérale de
contrôle nucléaire et tout ça nous est
apparu rationnel et cohérent donc
lorsqu'il a été décidé de
redémarrer on
a redémarré la la
conscience malgré les milliers de
fissures et la durée de vie dépassée de
tous les réacteurs les deux centrales
belges ont été prolongés jusqu'en
2025 mais les Belges ne sont pas les
seules à s'inquiéter 90 communes des
pays voisins ont décidé de porter
plainte devant la Cour de justice
européenne pour faire fermer la centrale
de TI
voilà reportage de François Goulin
Philippe Lambert question tout ça parce
qu'il faut fermer ces centrales nué
celle de tiange et celle de doule en
Belg évidemment mais écoutez vous auriez
une voiture qui a 400000 km et qui tombe
en panne tout le temps qui en plus de ça
crée dans votre garage des déchets qui
rendent votre garage inhabitable
qu'est-ce que vous feriez vous
remplaceriez votre voiture vite fait
autrement dit vous vous en
débarrasseriez parce que ça n'a aucun un
sens c'est de l'obstination c'est de
l'acharnement véritablement c'est de
l'acharnement thérapeutique mais en fait
on voit que c'est le produit et ça c'est
un peu un mal belge pas seulement mais
c'est un un mal belge de collusion entre
en effet le monde politique le monde
économique les autorités on confond les
les les les les gen et on voit bien
l'amateurisme total du gouvernement
actuel en Belgique mais je dois dire
aussi de ce point de vue-là de bien de
ses prédécesseurs qui continue à ignorer
le problème et cette lettre est
évidemment symbolique lorsqueon dit
écoutez il y a un problème très grave de
potentielle fusion du réacteur faites
quelque chose faites quelque chose c'est
gentil mais enfin je veux dire à un
moment s'il y a un risque aussi
important ben il faut le prendre à
bralco je rappelle quand même que tiange
se trouve à porté de Liège une des
principales agglomérations belges et
dououle d'enverse enverse qui non
seulement est une ville d'importance
belge mais d'importance européenne
puisque c'est un des principaux ports de
l'Union européenne et donc en cas
d'incident majeur dans ces centrales les
premières villes évacuées et on parle
bien de vill hein on vous parle pas de
petit village on parle bien de de ville
qui a évacué serait Liégé en ver ça n'a
absolument aucun sens alors la Belgique
n'est pas isolée là-dessus on sait le
nombre de centrales de DF qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt on va parler parce
que elle ne répondent pas aux normes non
plus et bien je pense qu'il est temps
qu'on prenne conscience que sortir du
nucléaire c'est maintenant et donc ça va
prendre du temps mais il faut il faut
entamer cette sortie maintenant et au
lieu de ça on retarde la sortie
Dominique r est-ce qu'onexagère pas un
peu trop he si l'agence de contrôle
l'agence fédérale belge a dit que
c'était bon est-ce qu'il y a des raisons
de s'inquiéter alors je pense qu'il y a
un problème de conf
clairement il y a un problème de
confiance dans à la fois les autorités
de contrôle mais aussi techniquement
dans les contrôles pourquoi on a
découvert que dans tous les réacteurs
d'aurs en France en Belgique mais
ailleurs aussi il y avait des
microofissures simplement parce que les
moyens de détection ont permis ont
progressé considérablement et ont permis
de les découvrir on sa pas depuis
combien de temps c'est là ni le danger
que ça représente il a donc
effectivement et Philippe Lambert se dit
bien c'est question de confiance les
contrôleurs sont-ils effectivement
méritetil notre confiance le matériel
est-il dangereux bon al il y a aussi un
autre problème c'est que je reprends la
métaphore de la voiture bon évacuer la
voiture mais après vous roulez dans quoi
parce que ah bah dans autre chose voilà
non mais pour l'instant est-ce que il y
a les moyens de donner l'électricité au
Belg si on ferme toutes les centrales
nucléaires alors c'est des questions qui
évidemment ne sont pas à mettre en
balance avec le risque d'un incident
majeur dans une zone aussi peuplée et
donc il y a un problème c'est un
problème de confiance c'est un problème
d'objectivité je crois que c'est très
important et c'est vrai que dans le
doute on peut se poser des questions
mais si je peux me permettre juste un
point sur la question de la qualité des
contrôles je veux bien admettre que les
techniques de contrôle se sont amélioré
qu'on peut détecter aujourd'hui des
choses qu'on détectait pas hier mais que
que constatons par exemple en France à
flamandville que le couvercle du de la
cuve du réacteur donc qui vient d'être
produit est lui aussi non conforme donc
ce que je veux dire c'est cette culture
un peu du Gemin foutisme dans dans la
filière Nucléa nuéire qui est aussi le
résultat d'externalisation et de recours
à la sous-traitance et cetera cette
culture de la sécurité s'est affaiblie
considérablement considérablement et
aujourd'hui on en paye l'époque assé
voir qu'en France par exemple on a
recouvert la France de centrale
nucléaire sans que jamais jamais il y
ait eu un débat démocratique au
Parlement c'est une décision de gens de
polytechniciens et d'énarc autour du
général de Gaulle poursuivi ensuite par
Pompidou Valérie clandestin qui ont
décid seul sans consultation de
recouvrir la France centrale nucléaire
est-ce que d'ailleurs la gauche s
emparée du sujet en France absolument
jamais les seuls qui s'en sont emparés
ce sont les écolos et ben alors que si
on faisait la même chose dans tout autre
domaine on entendrait des hurlement à
propos de l'absence de démocratie il y a
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il faut
s'arrêter réfléchir et se rendre compte
que et l'exemple belge là que le
nucléaire est un danger on le savait
depuis longtemps parce que le nucléaire
on a l'impression que c'est une énergie
propre oui parce que personne ne
réfléchit à ce que deviennent les
déchets donc en fait on renvoie ça à nos
petits enfants qui auront à gérer des
déchets donc c'est une filière en fait
qui dit produit une une électricité peu
coûteuse c'est c'est exactement
l'inverse parce que le traitement des
déchets va faire que en réalité
l'électricité qu'on consomme
gratuitement aujourd'hui demain il va
avoir une fortune donc les coûts de la
filière nucléaire n'ont jamais été
calculés donc il faut à un moment se
dire il faut en sortir et le seul les
seul qu'on était capable de le faire du
jour au lendemain c'est une démocratie
qui fonctionne ce sont les Allemands
fait c'estàdire que Angela Merkel a pris
seul au lendemain de fouushima une
décision alors c'était du brutal elle
n'a consulté personne il faut le
reconnaître mais néanmoins la le peuple
s'est retourné contre l'énergie
nucléaire elle en a tenu compte et elle
a stoppé elle essayé de sortir du
nucléaire une démocratie qui fonctionne
en France Dominique riquel et les
proncléaires sont majoritaires à droite
comme à gauche d'abord la décision
d'Angela Merkel est totalement
antidémocratique puisqueil y a eu aucune
consultation la deuxième remarque c'est
que après un moment d'enthousiasme il y
a beaucoup de choses à dire sur le
sortir du nuclére allemand actuellement
notamment sur le plan environnemental ça
nécessitera une autre discussion mais
c'est pas si simple et l'exemple
allemand a bien démontré la difficulté à
sortir du nuclére alors sur le principe
le problème n'est pas de savoir si à
terme il est pas préférable d'avoir des
énergies renouvelables à la place des
énergies nucléaires ou des énergies
fossiles c'est comment on fait en
combien de temps on fait et dans quelles
conditions démocratiques on le fait
alors ça c'est une question qui est pas
tranchée et c'est vrai dans interdit le
débat on commence jamais hein c'est
toujours c'est le fumeur qui dit
j'arrête demain quoira c'est vrai
Philippe mais il faut bien dire t les
jours non mais le dit c'est que en
France si actuellement on faisait un
débat démocratique sur le sujet je pense
pas sûr que les antinucléaires
l'emportent non si je peux rajouter
quelque chose sur anguela Merkel faut
quand même se rappeler que quand Angela
Merkel arrive au pouvoir elle annule la
loi de sortie de nucléaire adopté par le
gouvernement socialiste Ecolo en
Allemagne et donc elle dit c'est quoi
cette connerie il faut continuer
nucléaire 6 mois après Fukushima Angela
Merkel qui est physicienne donc c'est
pas une juriste c'est une physicienne
donc elle sait ce que c'est le nucléaire
dit oh le nucléaire est dangereux on va
arrêter alors je vais dire parlez-moi de
leadership politique je pense qu'il y a
une sérieuse dose d'opportunisme
là-dedans ceci dit la bonne décision
c'était en effet de sortir du nucléaire
est-ce qu'il faut pas renforcer le
regard international avec au moins une
agence européenne deôle c'est qu'on a
fait pour les banques c'est ce qu'on a
fait pour les banques on a dit oui
est-ce que est-ce que les contrôleurs
français sont pas un peu cul et chemis
avec les banques françaises donc on va
faire un gendarme européen en tout cas
au moins pour la zone euro des banques
et bien je pense qu'il faudrait
exactement la même chose pour le je
nucléaire est au moins aussi risqué pour
la sociéé que lesanques syéi ce qui se
passe en Belgique ça peut se passer en
France on sait que c'est NG ex GDF suè
qui gère les centrales en Belgique mais
aussi en
France mais c'est c'est exactement la
même chaîne de commandement qu'en
Belgique encore une fois c'est un
mélange des intérêts donc c'est un lobby
qui agit dans les dans les coulisses du
pouvoir il n'y a aucun contrôle
indépendant je veux dire c'est le lobby
nucléaire en France c'est quelque chose
qui est d'une puissance qui dépasse
l'imagin
interit LEB savez quand vous dites Dom
que en France aujourd'hui dans l'opin
publque aurait pas une majorité pour
nucléaire vous avez tout à fait raison
parce que ça fait 50 ans 60 ans qu'on
nous apprend à l'école moi j'ai appris
ça à l'école que le nucléaire c'est une
énergie propre que c'est absolument sans
danger on nous balance ça dans dans le
crâne jour et nuit les médias nous le
disent tous les jours mais vous en
faites pas on va pas nucléaire puis
regardez aujourd'hui en Allemagne ils
sont passés au charbon c'est bien pire
Paris est pollué à cause du charbon
le qui nous expque çaors lecléaire
gentil nucléaire onurait auun problème
donc de toute façon c'est est on est
véritablement à une mafia faut dire le
mot comme il est la mafia du nucléaire
et je vois pas très c'est vrai qu'en
France aujourd'hui le débat est interdit
comme il est interdit en Belgique mais
si ça peut-être que seul un incident de
type Fukushima qui serait dramatique
pour la Belgique ouvrira les yeux des
états c'est dramatique de se dire
ça ma les mot son fort oui le mot est
trop fort parce que en réalité si vous
regardez bien on PRRA encore plus de
recul on pourrait dire qu'il y a eu une
mafia du charbon bon g B en l'occurrence
et avec beaucoup d'intérêts des emplois
les mines les mineurs et cetera on voit
maintenant les problèmes que ça a pu
poser de dépendance et également
d'ailleurs de de de pollution bon on est
passé à une autre type d'énergie bon
l'hydroélectrique très bien et le
nucléire le nucléire a été parî de
toutes les vertus c'est vrai il est dans
une phase très critiqué c'est vrai
peut-être que la fission c'est pas le
bon système peut-être que la fusion ça
sera mieux on verra le vra différence
avec le charbon Dominique Riquet c'est
que le charbon c'était privé là la force
du nucléaire c'est que c'est l'état et
donc la filière est entièrement étatisé
c'estement c'est du ça c'est c'est le
problème du communisme je dire en
quelque sorte ce qui est frappant c'est
que c'est plutôt rassurant de savoir
que en matière de nucléaire ce qui est
quand même frappant c'est que comme dans
la banque l'investissement il est public
et la rente elle devient
c'est contb bel pay centr et c'est une
sociéé
privéurence jou de la r aujourd'ui c'est
quel chose c'est vraiment socialisation
des pertes et privatisation des Bénéfic
il faut sortir de cette logiot de la fin
ce sera le mot de la fin en tout cas
merci Merci à VOUS TR merci gauche pour
laette émission de
droite Merci à VOUS TR d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi c'est la fin d'do restez
avec nous sur les chaînes parlementaires
bye
[Musique]